[Music]
Um, oh
Ah,
yeah, ah, I
woke up.
Good morning, where have you been? I'm just going to go get this.
Yeah, I'm going to go get this. I need it,
so I need it. Um,
this is me and A's home, going back to college.  It's
all sorts of trouble, so until the investigation comes in,
I can take a break for now.From today onwards, the
rest of the college is on winter break.It's winter
break.I can't think of anything.Why
should I be worried?During that break, it's okay to take a break.  A
certain Tomoyo decided to
decorate the tree, do some year-end shopping,
and this year she would like to try popping crackers, so she would like to
listen to your selfishness.
[Music]
If not, I would like to
make potpourri with you.
[Music]
Of course.